welcome to ear biscuits the podcast
where two lifelong friends talk about
life for a long time i'm rhett and i'm
link this week at the round table of dim
lighting we're tackling the question
what would be our ideal wild
animal companion yeah and you may think
to yourself
why would you be worried about that it's
not that we're worried
we're we're we well all of a sudden
some we both experienced something via
a screen that has now piqued a certain
interest that i didn't know i had
uh this all this all goes back to uh
well how you may have experienced it
through the lens of my social media
shout out to red mc on twitter
okay i tweeted uh a while back
netflix got me crying over a damn
octopus
and i use the octopus emoji which i
don't think i've ever used
in any context oh you use the emoji why
not
did you type octopus and then it popped
up you're like oh there's an emoji
well of course cause you didn't know i
wouldn't have known that yeah yeah and i
was like
i don't know how to find an emoji if it
doesn't pop up there's certain times
when i'm like thinking
i feel like this conversation calls for
an emoji
but i'm so inadequate you you do the
visual search through
all the options because that's happened
to me a couple years yeah and then
then that that's just soul crushing and
then you're like you know what
is this a food this is this traffic sign
this is not me
this is this is not who i am and then i
just uh
you leave it off i'll leave it off well
um but if it pops up i'm like oh an
octopus
and twitter will do that for you so
we're of course
talking about the netflix documentary my
octopus teacher which i watched
and then came to work tonight and you
were just gushing about this
this netflix documentary right so we're
going to talk about that so
and we're also going to talk about some
other animal friendships
and then we're going to talk about the
like we said at the beginning the wild
animal friendships that we might want to
personally instigate now let me say
spoiler alerts forthcoming because
actually spoilers forthcoming is a
spoiler alert
um yeah you might want to go and watch
octopus teacher my
it's called my octopus teacher on
netflix now
we're going to discuss it in great
detail i do not think that anything that
we're going to say
is going to make it where you don't want
to then also
watch it but but if you want if you're a
spoiler reverse person
you want to go watch it right now not
even that i would even
you know it's i think yeah there's a
couple of things in the documentary that
i just want to speak about plainly
that i i do think it's better to
experience
uh cold which is why i did not
tell my family you were talking to
christy about it
it wasn't at work or maybe it was a work
and then no no i was talking about it
when we had our uh i actually
invited you uh and your wife over to
take a dip in the hot tub
oh yeah that's when you were talking
about the first sort of like hot tub
dip of covered and then i i went back
home
and i think it was that night or maybe
the next night and uh
christy poor girl she has gotten herself
into a uh
a binge watching spree of one
tree hill i didn't get a permission
there's only one way to get somebody out
of that
is with an octopus
to pull you out of one tree hill she
goes to bed a lot earlier than me on a
weekend
and so i'll burn the midnight oil and
i'll watch something and i was
you know she was upstairs she was
and she went upstairs earlier and i was
like what you're doing she's like oh i'm
i think i'm just going to watch one tree
hill i'm like okay
okay i'm not going to watch that that's
that's your that's the thing that
and you know what there's a lot of
nostalgia i'm not going to make fun of
all before she well she said you know
what turns out i haven't seen it all
she did i would just catch it when i
caught it but it wasn't a bit it was
like
before the days of benjamin and now
she's like putting all the pieces
together and reliving her
i think we were we were newlyweds how
many pieces are there to put together
oh well i mean there's just one tree in
one hill it turns out there's
there's a surrounded community and lots
of i don't know there's basketballs
involved i've got
there's and there's a kid there's a
couple with
multiple basketballs i don't know how
many
but i went downstairs and i watched the
uh my octopus
teacher and then the next morning she
was like what what'd you end up doing
and i told her and she was like i wanted
to watch that rhett wouldn't shut up
about it and i i
i kind of wanted to watch it my wife was
upset that i watched it without her but
so i i got into it not knowing how
impactful it was going to be on me
personally i did not
tell her anything about it that you
hadn't already told her and i didn't
tell the kids anything but we got
uh the kids to watch it and i watched it
again twice
i watched it twice was it good the
second time it was it was good the
second time
well and i i rarely watch anything the
second time and it was still good so i
just want to give people permission yeah
because there's permission to listen i'm
not a spoiler adverse
person i know you are but so if you're
like i'm even saying you can
you can you can still listen to us and
then watch it right what i'm saying is
but it's not ideal
some because i don't like telling people
who've just tuned in
to use an antiquated term to this
podcast to then go enjoy some other
media that's just not good business
that's not good business so i'm just
saying that you can go and watch it
if you really want to um but if you're
listening and watching it and you're
seeing it from the perspective of the
filmmaker is going to be much better
than us talking about it
and then you should come back and listen
to us so if you
again what i was trying to say was it's
not just about spoilers is if you
if you know you you're looking for
things to watch
and you're committed to listening to
this and you promise that you're going
to come back and listen to this
if you promise then i'm going to say you
know what
don't stop this right now yeah if you
can do it in that order
right but we're also going to talk about
other things if we set you free if it's
true love you will come back
we've we both have other stories
that are in a similar vein of that
of the octopus teacher unlikely animal
human
like legitimate friendships yeah
like friendships that are kind of
mind-blowing that i did not know were
possible
and now that we do it might change the
direct trajectory of our lives
entire lives um but we're going to talk
about that stuff too i got i got some
i've read up on some you've read up on
some so so we're going to get to that
but i'm
i'm mostly going to dig deep into my
soul because that seems to be
what happens in these situations there's
a
something happens on the soul level when
people
spark friendships with wild animals did
you weep during my octopus teacher
i felt the pressure to weep because you
not only tweeted about it but then you
you talked about it at length i think
we've established it and i didn't it
doesn't take much for me to weep
while watching something i weep during
commercials
occasionally um i wept but you've
learned
why i've learned why i thought from
therapy you learned why
well it's a combination i don't want to
bait you here no it's a combination of
two things
number one um i am actually in the i
don't know the
i don't know the name of it but i'm in
like what would be called believe it or
not
the sensitivity triad of the enneagram i
don't know if that's the correct term
but there's basically
a few numbers that are actually
significantly
they're all i'm actually on the
sensitive side of the spectrum of
people but i also have a personality
based in all kinds of things you know
and that is has kind of shielded me from
my emotions so there's
a this weird thing that happens where
there's actually
a very high level of sensitivity that is
happening
in me compared to an average person
but i have sort of a shell of a
personality that will make you think
that i'm not
experiencing the things and actually i'm
so good at constructing the personality
that i can actually keep the sensitivity
and the emotions and the feelings from
my own brain
like hidden from myself and so i would
have told you before therapy
i am not a sensitive person yeah i cry
at commercials sometimes my dad's the
same way he's always done that
but but that's actually a sign of that
yeah it means there's
there is a deep level of sensitivity
that exists in my person
that has to find a way to come out in
order for me to be
in equilibrium and so what ends up
happening is
often instead comes out dealing with
like sitting there and like crying about
something that's happening to me
personally
i will see something happening between a
man and an octopus on netflix
and begin to weep because there's a lot
of potential for sensitivity there now
that's not to say
it seems that i'm implying that i cry in
like things that
pertain to my real life and it's like
that doesn't happen either
so i might have a couple of layers
but anyway but you've now been we're
talking about for less than a year
we're right we're gonna i'm gonna i'm
gonna divert this stream
back to um the streaming of
the documentary so i and you'll tell me
when
when you cried i have a i have a good
guess but i it's actually
multiple times oh okay well then i
i have three guesses uh
but yeah it's uh it i mean it's my it's
gonna be my wreck
at the end of this thing spoilers
spoiler alert there it is no no no
they're not gonna hang on for the wreck
so this thing just just to give a little
overview
uh via wikipedia just for the sake of
time my octopus teacher
came out on the 4th of september
of this year 2020. it's 85 minutes long
it's it's out of south africa and it is
in english the film shows how in 2010
foster uh who is craig foster he's a
filmmaker that then became the subject
of this film
that uh uses footage he shot and some
footage that
was shot by another cinematographer um
and then directed by two other people
um so foster began free diving in
a cold underwater kelp forest at a
remote location in
false bay near cape town south africa so
we're talking about the horn of africa
like the southernmost point
in africa which you know it's down there
it's getting it's cold it's getting cold
down there and this dude
would swim in the water in just a pair
of shorts and we're talking about like
like not not uh scuba diving we're
talking about snorkeling he had like a
snorkel
and a mask he spins a weight belt in
order to kind of get down into the kelp
forest
in a pair of shorts it's called free
diving he was holding his breath
to go down and it was
he said the the water would get as cold
as i had i had to google
the conversion but like 45 degrees
fahrenheit
yeah it's actually that sounds crazy to
me it's unnatural
in 60 degree water that's
frigid well feeling just last night
i jumped into my pool as you can see
we're the jacket boys today we've got on
jackets
jacket weather is finally here in
california
and i got into my pool last night and it
said on the thermometer that it was 70
degrees
but i felt like i was getting into a
refrigerator
so to think about and when we did the
ice bath it was in the 50s
55 50 so 45 degrees we're talking and
it's phenomenal he just he said at one
point
early on in the documentary when he's
you know it's he said
after a year because he dove every day
every day without exception after a year
he says you start to crave the cold i'm
like
after a year i don't you know anything
that
catastrophically numbing
and painful but don't you want it when
he said that
you know but yeah but i i want it if it
would like maybe after a week
you start to crave the call after a year
you're starting to crave the call
well and a little just a little bit of
background that what got him to this
point so
he was a documentary filmmaker he is a
documentary filmmaker and he essentially
had
a midlife crisis right he had been
working on some documentaries and one in
particular that was like following a
tribe
uh somewhere in sub-saharan africa and
you know he had a kid and he was he
began to just kind of feel
disconnected and felt like he needed to
drop
everything didn't know if he would ever
film anything again didn't know if he
was going to pick up a camera again
went back to the horn of africa to get
into the water because his family had
had a house which
did you see at the house that they
showed that was literally below the
title line so like the waves crashed
it how did you build that house waves
would go
into the ways would go into the house so
and we're talking about like on a cliff
not
like sandy yeah and that's what he grew
up doing so he wanted to go back to the
roots
and he would like because he went skin
diving as a kid
and so he just went back there not
filming and then
he he came upon
an octopus not a special octopus
just a normal octopus in fact it's what
is it called octopus
communists or something yeah yeah i
don't know what it's a common octopus
that is not what it is but it's
it is just a common octopus and so the
the things that he
learned observed and started to film and
share with the viewer
uh were just
amazing so you know
i want to get into that but first we
should promote some merch let's get it
out of the way okay let's do that at
this point
uh do you know chunk
i do know chung got a sweatshirt and a
t-shirt
it took him a wh it took chunk a while
to talk us
and to actually launching you know
selling some merch for them
but it's the type of things you could
wear so relentless how often they they
contact us and ask us all these
ridiculous things but we said okay
now that you don't really make many
appearances on our channels anymore
now is the time to begin selling your
merch well here's the thing if you're a
fan of
chunk uh you'll enjoy wearing this
but it's also a cool thing to wear
because people will think that it is a
real band
and it just seems
just on the cusp of believability so if
it would spark
either strange looks or maybe even a
conversation that's dangerous yeah the
chunk world tour
only at amazon.com mythical now
one of the things about octopuses is
octopi
is that correct octopi through the power
of the internet
i think that most people who have an
internet connection
have learned that they're smart that
they're smart this is something that
like
five years ago maybe most people didn't
know but now most people are like yeah
i've seen that crazy video where the
octopus like
changes color i didn't know the
octopuses could
octopi could change color and could do
weird things like
walk on two legs and sprout horns
over their eyes and then i also didn't
know that if you're doing
the iq thing the animal iq thing that
these things would actually
rank just a little bit above a dog
in intelligence which seems nuts to me
and on top of that two-thirds
of their cognitive power is in their
limbs
wild i mean they evolved on a completely
different uh branch
and you know when we were hanging out
and you were gushing and gushing and
gushing about it like an octopus
mike our friend ended up saying he was
like you know the the way that
that they're so intelligent if they
if the way that they evolved if they
didn't
live if they only why why can't i not
put this thought together
they only live a year if they lived as
long as we do
evolutionarily speaking they would be
running the earth
that they would have they would have
developed technology
and they would have vehicles to come on
land and farm everywhere
that's why it's so remarkable nothing
that in the movie arrival
the the alien beings are octopus-like
and i thought that was super
you know appropriate the balancing
factor for me is that they're
beautiful gross oh not beautiful to me
i'm like
oh gosh like the first thing i told you
was like yeah but
when i think about an octopus i think
about them being able to squeeze
through tight places because they're
just so gelatinous
and i just get this i went to the
aquarium and i saw one put all of its
arms through this little hole
and i was like what are you doing and
then all of a sudden
it like the bulbous head of the octopus
it just kind of started shoving its own
head
through this hole and that was very
disturbing to me i was like you're gonna
get stuck
no one's gonna be able to yank you out
of there and it was just but then it
effortlessly went through but it was
just like
gross i think the thing that's scary to
me about them
first of all they're scarier on land
than they are in the water because
they're not moving very gracefully
but there's also and i don't know if
they're not typically on land
but so no like you see there was a scene
where this one was on
you see the videos where like they get
like caught in a net and then they try
to get back into the ocean and it's kind
of crazy there's some
good youtube videos flapping around but
i think there's a movie an old movie
where there's like an octopus that's
killing a bunch of people it might be a
squid but there's a beak
it's called octopussy it's the james
bond film
there's a beak in there up in the like
if you were to underneath
if you were to take the legs in like
expose it yeah which
doesn't happen in this particular
particular documentary
there's there's a mouth in there that is
powerful and can do
things and i'm scared of i'm scared of
things like that well
like he talks about how there's a dr he
calls it a drill
where he can drill a hole into a shell
at a very particular spot that will make
the the
the mollusk or whatever that's inside
just like let go of the shell
and then well it can it injects it with
some kind of venom that paralyzes it at
a certain spot but it's got to be a very
particular part of the snail inside the
shell
okay so to continue the story he dies
every single day for a year and then
at some point he just runs into this
octopus
and he realizes that okay so octopuses
this is another thing i didn't know
octopuses
i'm going to say octopuses i know it's
wrong but i just octopi sounds stupid
octopuses have dens
so there's like a place at a particular
rock under a little rock where this
thing
lives garden an octopus garden
and it and he's like okay in the shade
uh
this is where i live and this is where
i'm gonna be every time you come and see
me
so he's like okay this is cool and he
decided to go there every single day and
in the opening of the documentary
there's a sound bite of him saying
something like and there
but there was a boundary that i
discovered
that you just don't cross and i'm like
is he gonna
is he gonna is he gonna expose himself
to this i thought that he was gonna
potentially make love to the octopus
because i was like i don't think this
would be on netflix
because you hear about the like the
scientist who had the relationship with
the dolphin
and then there was a there was a sexual
component or at least there was like a
there was a
there was a masturbation component in
order to
get the the dolphin to be more compliant
and
today we're not talking about that right
so that's that's
we're not saying but it did conjure
those fears
among my brain cells but but that's not
what they meant but we can get back to
that what that
you know what that the boundary was a
relational one and there's also a
documentarian part of this thing because
it's the feat of filmmaking the fact
that like
the things that he observed like he
observed the octopus using it like
wanting to inspect the human and then
using a shell as a shield
and then slowly approaching behind like
holding it up like a shield and then
finally another tentacle out finally
making contact with him
and then realizing that there's a
curiosity
on the part of this octopus that he
never named
i mean he never gave the octopus a name
but that's a good point i think
observation
and that's the boundary i think he's
part of the boundary wasn't trying to
make it he wasn't trying to make it a
pet and he was also as you will see in a
second not trying to
insert himself into the natural flow of
nature
that was going to uh
happen with this octopus we can gush all
day about all the things we learned
about
octopi but you can get that from the
documentary but the thing that was
interesting
was if i mean he could see
the his the the octopus predator
swimming around like pajama shark and
then
he was scared and he would go back every
day like what's gonna happen
and then freaking he films
a shark attack his friend the octopus
i mean they were they had a bond at this
point the octopus
knew him would come out they would swim
together
you know he would like swim on his he
the octopus would
she would hold on to his hand and it
would like it was it would like
the octopus would like come up and
settle on his
chest and give him a hug and because he
he's not wearing a wetsuit that's part
of the deal he wanted to be as close to
nature as possible so just an
almost naked man but he wouldn't have
this octopus just nestling on his
chest he didn't reach out grabbed the
octopus and put him on no the octopus
did yes
he left the octopus instigate take the
initiative but the one
you left out an important point which
was
he was filming it once he was like oh
i'm gonna start filming this thing
i'm going to take my camera down there
he had developed this trust this bond
and then he it was following him and he
dropped the lens
off of the camera and it spooked the
octopus
and it did not go back to its den so the
next day he goes back the thing is not
in its den
it goes about the next day it's not an
instant he's like oh crap i've ruined
this relationship we had built this
trust and you've broken up that
was the first time i cried i was already
crying
when he had the bond and then he broke
the bond oh so you you didn't cry
when he successfully tracked her down
and reconnected oh no i cried again
that's number two yeah well then was
number three i i
i mean it was at least three times i
mean the big point of
horror was him filming this shark
getting attacked
attack attack her and
rip off one of her arms and just
eat it and then it gets to that
it gets to that boundary because he
didn't stop it from happening
but then he says i couldn't resist
basically he couldn't resist helping so
he you know she's
she's in she's holding her back to the
den yep on her own he does seven limbs
he's tempted to help but he doesn't help
he just films her going back to her den
limping with one less arm which has her
brain in it
yeah lost a part of her brain and then
she's like she's too weak to even change
color yeah she just turns white and so
but he did
crack open shells
like some muscles or muscles or
something and
serve it to her to have some nourishment
and she took it she took it but he said
it didn't i don't think it did much good
but i think he might have been saying
that because
he crammed down he crossed his own
boundary
which i'm like dude wait you know when
you're in a relationship
with an animal all bets are off like
it's not a pet
but it's a there was a bond there and he
freaking
yeah of course i totally understand that
he had to like do what he could to
to help but it was it seemed like a
little little
too little too late until she
freaking grew her arm back did you i
didn't
i forgot that that was possible i didn't
know it was possible
she jaw dropped she grew the arm back
and so she had eight limbs again and she
kind of came back to life and again so
he lost contact with her tracked her
down learn how to track
her movements by looking at the sand on
the bottom of the ocean but he's got
reunites with her watches her get
attacked by the shark she loses the limb
and then she gets back in business
and the in the sort of the the it goes
on relationship continues
and then lo and behold
the same dang gone shark comes back or
one of the sharks that hunts at this
reef
comes back at this point this is when
my mind started i was like am i
experiencing
reality correctly at this point yeah
because the octopus
has the ability to pick up
all these shells and ball itself
up and shield itself it looks like a
soccer ball
that's made out of all these shells that
it's holding
mm-hmm and there's a name for that as
well i can't remember what it was
and the the octa i do not think that
this uh
this behavior was ever documented before
he observed it because he says he
remembers seeing that the
the first time he ever came in contact
with the octopus it was in that state of
this soccer ball with the shells and he
was like what the hell is this thing
right then you realize it's a octopus
protecting it and then there's like epic
battle with the shark that still is
trying to eat the
soccer ball of shells and then okay two
things
two remarkable things happen during the
shark attack the first thing that
happens is
is that the the once the octopus
the shark picks up the octopus and is
shaking it around because it realizes
okay this isn't a soccer ball this is an
octopus
but the octopus gets away and swims out
of the water gets on the shore on a rock
and eventually has to get back in the
water because it can't stay out too long
and at that point it gets on the shark's
back
and rides the shark because it knows
that the shark can't eat it as long as
it's riding on it like it's a freaking
horse
but it rode it as a as a soccer ball of
shells
yeah right it kept itself in the shells
while it did this so that the fish was
so that the shark was totally confused
and then when it when it brushed up
against
some some coral it just
ever so normally it just
brushed itself off and floated away
this thing is so freaking smart and
that's why you observe this thing every
day for a year
and you're making this bond with it and
you
you're saying okay i'm now going to film
my best ocean friend getting eaten alive
how much do you think was the the
footage that we were seeing in the
documentary
was the footage that was captured in the
moment when it happened
and how much was like filler like
filling it like
going back and filming later to make it
make sense like pickups like movie
pickups like
i do think the octopus is smart enough
to to comply to pickups like hey can you
get on the back of that
pajama shark again and you know it's
like we kind of we're going to look at
the continuity photos you're going to
get the same shells in the same because
every single thing that would happen
i think he captured all they would he
had incredible shots of it and i think
that was
a level of obsession that i i totally
understand it's like again you're making
this bond
and then you don't know what's going to
happen every day and it's like is this
the day that i come back
and the octopus is just not there
you know it's been attacked and it's
just gone um
am i gonna have to track it again but
that's why it's so amazing to me that he
didn't intervene
except in that one breach
you know with feeding and then it
you know it's like comes back and it's
like there's there's another octopus
they're mating
they they've made it and then it's like
he knows that she's gonna die at that
point so he's just
he's coming back every day to see that's
the end of the life cycle
yeah only a year something that smart at
what point in the process
do you think that the inner filmmaker
there's a spark sometimes especially
when you're doing documentary
film there's a spark uh
we don't have a whole lot of experience
with this but i do remember when we were
making looking for miss locklear which
is really the only documentary we've
ever made full-length documentary
and once the search
for our teacher became much larger and
became about
the struggle of the lumbee people and
like
we found ourselves in washington dc at a
hearing
filming john mccain talk about
you know the indian affairs committee
there was this moment
somewhere along the lines where i was
like we got something here right
he was at what point do you think he
understood the potential for what he was
creating
i mean he was a nature documentarian i
think i think
had to be pretty early and i do think
that was the factor
because i g there's i'm not that
familiar with them but i just
i have to believe that there's these
there's these rules of you don't
intervene you know well there's a famous
photo
that won uh a prize of some sort
whatever the photo prize is
um the starving child right
um but i don't remember when it was from
so there's a journalistic principle that
applies to nature as well
complete the thought though there's a
there's a picture of a starving child
that was walking to get
food and this journalist photojournalist
took a picture of the child
but did not assist the child and i think
the story goes that the child died
and when people found out about that
they were like well okay what's more
important your journalistic principles
or the life of this child
this is a this isn't a child this is an
octopus we're talking about but there is
this sort of
commitment to these journalistic
principles that he went into the process
knowing that like
if i'm going to make this into something
i
i i understand the type of criticism
that i'm going to receive especially
when it's an animal
for intervening right
any and he really he held he held strong
i couldn't have done that
and i i found myself being angry with
him when the when the
octopus was in that epic battle as a
boulder
because he could have just reached out
and like slapped a shark but maybe
that's a good
point to analyze because an
extraordinary thing was documented that
happened
you know it's like you don't want to see
a human hand come in there and like
thump the shark away yeah it this is not
the story
you know he he was he was he was
presenting her story
not their story but really
i mean the direct when the directors
took the footage they presented his
story
but it was more about how you know he
had a son and there was a connection to
it was what did the octopus teach him uh
and there was you know his his takeaway
was more of uh
that we're all connected right
well it raises a lot a larger question
which i think we'll get into
as we begin to talk about some of these
other scenarios which is
what part of this incredible connection
between this animal that's more
intelligent than i ever understood
uh you know and i think about you know
my relationship with barbara your
relationship with jade who's currently
in your lap
um and definitely i attribute human
emotions
and human instincts to barbara like when
barbara looks at me with a
she gives me a facial expression that
may be like well she's confused
right now or she is annoyed right now or
she's happy right now
and again a lot of that is me projecting
a human understanding onto a dog's face
even though
we do know that dogs since
you know being domesticated have
developed these things that only exist
with them and don't exist with wolves
like the ability to
make eye sustained eye contact with a
human to get
to to communicate via eye contact that's
not something that would happen with a
wolf
but even so it makes sense that there's
a there is some sort of emotional
connection like i feel like when i'm
doing
my stretching in the morning and barbara
comes and gets on my
chest and like puts her head on my face
or licks me or whatever
i don't think that she's just i'm doing
this because you're going to feed me
later that might be a part of it
but i do think that she's there is an
emotional component to it
and but how much of this
was an understanding that this octopus
had
which is like and again they wouldn't
put it in human terms
but like how much of it do you think was
insofar as an octopus can consider a
human a friend
that was what was going on it seemed
that way
it really did i mean like the
he wasn't he the he
she the octopus was not getting anything
from him he was
except for that one time he was not
feeding her he was not
doing anything except uh
like being interesting you know she was
interested
and then there there was a connection
there was a form of relationship like
curling up on his chest and stuff like
that or just like
swimming together there was i mean he he
witnessed her
being playful with fish you know once
you really understand how something
works
and it's extremely you know i'm so glad
that we got a dog
because i i you know it's
until you experience a connection with
an animal it's just you know it's not
something that
it's just not something you can judge
from the outside and that's what i was
doing
right so it's it
it does something within a human soul i
think to have a
to have a connection with an animal
let's get to some of these because i
think this
i think these pro are an exploration of
that point yeah
well i'm going to talk about uh din dim
tell me about den
den dem the penguin so
in may of 2011 a guy named
joao pierre which i would just call
mr de souza from this point on okay uh
and i'm reading from uh uh points from a
cnn article in 2016 about this
a humble retired bricklayer rescued
an injured penguin in the state of rio
de janeiro
okay or rio de janeiro uh and the
flightless bird was covered in oil and
uh unable to move so i
uh oil spill it was you know one of
those situations where you got a bird
covered in oil
so de souza took him we're not talking
sexy oil we're talking right yeah this
is brutal i'm not a lubricant well it is
i guess it but you know yeah
not ky jelly uh d'souza took him under
his wing
uh pun and nurtured him back to health
thoroughly cleaning oil residue on the
penguin's body and feeding him for days
until he was fit enough to return to the
water
so this guy basically lives on like an
island nation
uh lives on the beach essentially um
not an island nation an island area near
rio
so he took him to another nearby island
to set him free
to set uh den dem free and later of
course he hadn't named him at this point
later the that day he hears some
squawking
in his backyard and he's like holy crap
the penguin is back he came back to the
backyard
and he the penguin now he wasn't like he
didn't put him in an enclosure he didn't
treat him as a pet
he did feed him and he did touch him
well
this penguin stayed with de souza for 11
months
and then he shed his annual coat
of feathers molted or whatever the term
is
and suddenly was gone like he was
nothing but feathers
he disappeared no that penguin was just
a ball of feathers
all of a sudden all of a sudden he was
not in his backyard
okay so at this point d'souza is
thinking okay that was a weird
but awesome thing this short-lived
relationship with this penguin that i
nursed back to health but then the next
year
he came back came back to the backyard
and that's when you cry in the movie
and then he left again he's marching
haven't you seen march of the penguins
and it turned to do something right and
for years every year since 2011
he has come back to his backyard at the
same time it's like an extended period
of time he like
comes back in the middle of the summer
and
stays until like february and then goes
away
and then comes back at the same exact
time now it makes you cry
cry a little you know you can make
yourself cry it makes you well up
because
just imagine his you know the feeling he
did he did this
you know selfless act of rescuing well
you want to cry look at that a
flightless bird
look at that look at this video oh no
you have to describe what you're seeing
here he is this is this is him he's
waddling he's waddling up
and he just puts his he nuzzles him
he puts his beak on his face and he
doesn't do this he kisses him and he
doesn't do this
with any other humans he doesn't allow
any if any other human tries to touch
him he bites them
oh wow but he lets him give him baths
he's giving him
a shower and then he and he just let
he's hauled him this is a humble brick
link that's a humble brick layer i mean
and just you know
it's just it's such a rewarding
connection it's like you you do a
selfless act
and then it's recognized it's like i owe
you my life
i'm gonna come back and i'm gonna nuzzle
you only you i am not tame
well i am allegiant i don't want to take
any of the magic out of it
but i'm gonna but i'm gonna tell you
something that has been theorized about
this particular situation now the first
thing is
for those of you who are like how did
you know it's the same penguin
well there were some scientists who
asked the same question
and so in 2016 they tagged this uh
they drew the graffiti on him
they tagged the penguin so they could
keep up with his location and sure
enough it's the same penguin and he
travels like 5 000
miles wow but what but
okay while the this is from the article
while the idea of a penguin returning to
visit every year seems surreal
krajewski who is the scientist said that
most
uh magellanic or
just like magellan with an ic magellanic
penguins are very loyal to their partner
and nesting site
they nest in the same place every year
and with the same partner
so in the circuitry of this penguin's
brain
is a commitment to monogamy and so one
theory
is that he sees d'souza as his mate he
sees it as a
another penguin and so he has this
tendency to bond and connect and almost
imprint on this other
being and it just happens that hey yeah
i you guys go and you spend time with
other things that look like birds and
you do interesting sexual things with
them and it makes baby penguins
i just go hang out with a humble
bricklayer well you should see the brick
he can lay
but still it's beautiful and it's sweet
i'd like to see your mate tammy lay
brick
right exactly that's
dendum i mean i i read an
article about eureka the fish that in
in in japan um there's this uh
underwater shrine sacred to the shinto
religion
and there is a caretaker of this shrine
so he like he scuba dives down there
uh he hiroyuki
arakawa and uh there's this like
i'll call it an ugly fish i'm just gonna
say it
it's a ugly like it's a bottle
bottle hit bottlenose like bulbas-headed
sheep sheep's head ross
fish it's not pretty there's no octopus
and this thing comes up and uh for 25
years
he greets her with a kiss on the
forehead but i watch the footage of it i
think you watched the footage too
a little less impressive it's just a big
old fish getting
petted on the forehead and then it looks
like it wants something yeah
it looks like it was something i mean it
snapped at him and it seemed like it was
eating something later
and then but he kisses it on the head
that that doesn't count
for me i mean it's like it's
that's not a that's not special it's
just like hey a fish knows you
are going to show up every day and maybe
feed it or at least kiss it on the head
and i bet a little something comes out
of your mouth that it tastes a fish
has got to be and this fish looks really
stupid i mean like
i think all fish are probably pretty
dumb this fish looks like
especially stupid but i mean the fact
that it's like 25 years i think
is just a testament to you don't have to
be that smart to make it 25 years in the
ocean but let me tell you about this a
crocodile
okay okay i got i got another one too i
i just want i want to go ahead and skip
to the crocodile okay all right because
i think it's
this is crazy all right um
a dude named cheeto is in uh
is in he's in central america
he's a fisherman he finds a crocodile
like a small crocodile that's been shot
by a farmer because it was like coming
out
it was coming he has cattle and like
shot it shot this crocodile
in the head like in the eye to kill it
but then he finds it
and he nurses it back to health over
three years
and like he's like he's like chewing
stuff for this
crocodile and like and then giving it to
the like showing the crocodile oh you
need to eat this
and then like feeding that stuff and
like being he's like demonstrating
chewing
yeah to a crocodile and it worked a
crocodile
yeah in this thing how big is this thing
uh well
it was it was small but then over the
three years of it regaining
its its vigor this thing grew to 16 feet
long
that's a big it's a huge crocodile
um and then he he named it pocho
yeah and he puts it he puts it back
and he once it recovers he like he he
sends it away
and then he gets up the next morning and
that thing has come back and is in his
yard
and then he does it again does it three
times and the crocodile poche just keeps
coming back
and hanging out in his yard he doesn't
want to leave
cheeto and so then chito
is compelled to spend more and more time
with this crocodile to the point
that uh his wife starts to think he's
sneaking around on him and like
uh and then it realizes it's crocodile
but gets jealous
that he's jealous and they get a divorce
he wasn't making love with it was he
no he wasn't he was just spending more
time with the crocodile he's spending
with her and he's quoted as saying
another wife i could get pocho
was one in a million well you could say
that again he did get another wife
and they had a daughter and the
daughter's not allowed to like be around
pocho but the
pocho will not leave so like he's like
spending all this quality time
and learning all the intricacies of like
how the crocodile looks and all this
stuff
and you start swimming with the
crocodile and there's like a nat
geo documentary which incidentally is
shot by the same person
who was a cinematographer on uh
my octopus teacher really yeah
and in the opening shot you see this
croc a huge crocodile like in the water
with his eye and just eye
eyes at the water level and then his
mouth opens and you know you know how
you see a crocodile's mouth just
gape open and and then you realize
no this is not the crocodile's mouth
gaping open with
there's like a huge bald head in its
mouth no
the crocodile's mouth is shut and a
bald-headed
man named chito is underneath the
crocodile pushing his head up
and revealing himself this is like
the opening shot of this uh documentary
any like he rides on its back and he's
i mean this is this is this is a a
reptile
you would think that this couldn't
happen because again the way that the
the the reptilian brain they're not
developed
they're not that smart i mean it's like
yeah it's
we have a number of layers of brain on
top of the core of our brain
basically instinctual that's what's so
crazy about the octopus
is that it's evolutionarily so much more
separated
but yeah a crocodile i mean
he but why doesn't he eat cheeto i mean
his name is
cheeto after all it's spelled
differently
but the it's not as compelling as the
octopus thing because you can't
attribute as much intelligence to the
crocodile but i mean
there's enough there's a lot more risk
though there's there is a bond but and
there are many documented cases of
people
like with you know after years and years
of having a pet reptile
and he was he was a pet but he was still
in he was still free to go
he's free to go now they they'll they'll
turn on you and just kill you
all right didn't he die he died he died
at age of 50 in 2011.
but the interesting thing is how the
crocodile yeah cheeto described it as
being whenever he would play with the
crocodile he said it was like being with
god
like the dude was obsessed with this
connection because it just
it can become so i'll say magical
you you're able to cross this impossible
boundary
and it's i mean it's you could tell
in his interviews just how meaningful it
was to him to have that connection
and it is interesting to explore like
how much of that is
you know projection but it's real for
him and it's
in it's well and it is important well we
have a tendency you know
post enlightenment especially in the
western world we have a tendency to do
what we're doing which we kind of just
naturally do which is
to try to break it down to just its
naturalistic
elements but there is an emotional
component
well it seems i would say there even a
spiritual component right potentially so
what i'm getting at is
insofar as that's what he did yeah when
you talk about the idea of
oneness right and the idea that
consciousness is a thing that exists i'm
not saying i subscribe to this idea
but it is a very intriguing way to look
at the universe and the idea
that there may not necessarily be there
could be
uh a god who is somehow
separate from this creation and was the
one who set everything in emotion
but to me there's a slightly more
interesting idea
that in many ways seems more compelling
that god is in everything right and is
sort of
the universe is essentially a physical
expression
of a consciousness that exists that you
and i
and this wooden desk are all a part of
this is something that i used to
i when i i'll just break in and say i
don't know if it's
it may be more interesting and
compelling
it is interesting compelling to me as
well but it may be because it's a little
more
it's a newer idea to us but well i'm
going to talk about that because i
actually feel like
i remember when i used to hear about
different eastern
religions and and i heard about it in
the context of growing up in a in a
conservative christian home
in a church where the way that we would
interpret say hinduism buddhism whatever
like when i learned that there were all
these specific
gods associated with different objects
in hinduism to me
i was like that's ridiculous right i
remember thinking that as a kid i was
like
that's really that seems kind of that
seems sort of archaic and it seems like
something like an
old kind of idea that you would
attribute
you would find a god in a rock mystic it
was it was mystical
or i'm what i'm saying is i belittled
the idea i'm saying i'm not saying
it was mystical i i'm what i'm saying is
i look down on the idea i thought that
it was a bad way to look at the universe
i thought that
it was a simple way to look at the
universe and i was like
when you can or an ignorant yeah yeah
like that kind of makes sense like
maybe those people haven't evolved to a
place where they can appreciate the
idea of a personal creator
god but one but one of the things that
i'm kind of
reevaluating again i don't know where i
fall in this perspective
but when i think about that i'm like oh
it isn't necessarily
just a simple the super simple sort of
dismissive view that i had which was
attributing a god or magic to every
single thing
but to me it's a way of kind of
expressing that idea
that there is life there is
god whatever the word you want to use
there is consciousness
in all things and sort of more of a
sense of fabric
of the universe right and so i do think
there's been times in my life where i
have felt
connected to things it would be like
it's weird to feel connected to a plant
right but if you go back from a
scientific standpoint to the point where
well we come from the same place we're
all star dust at
one point the same atoms that make up
that plant
you know the same atoms that make up me
are going to become the same atoms that
make up a plant that make up an animal
that make up the next jade
and what i'm getting at is
are you using jade as an ex a visual
example right now i am yeah
and so your connection with jade
is again the western enlightened view is
that this is a lesser creature
that is here for your benefit this is
here for you
the idea that you're human and therefore
you must exercise dominion over all
things on earth
and that everything is here for your
exploitation
there's a different way to look at
things which is we're all part of the
same system
in a much more integrated and thorough
way than we ever appreciated and when
you do when you think about it like that
maybe what's happened between cheeto and
pocho is
a sort of strange it's not an anomaly
but it's an expression of that type of
connection that can happen between
beings i'm not gonna swim with a croc to
find god but he did
right he did and it and it uh
his second wife was with it
so yeah yeah it i mean it it is
interesting i do want you to get to the
lion
you know i uh i had heard about this but
like this is a
it's the the relationship narrative
associated with this is uh is flooring
well and this is a video that you've
seen if you're one of the 100 million
people who have watched it
uh christian the lion you may have seen
about 10 years ago
there was a video that went viral and
it's it's obviously like
old footage it's from the late 60s
and i think the original version doesn't
even have any sound but there's these
two
very hippie looking white dudes with
long hair and bell bottoms
and they're like out in africa yeah and
next thing you know
there's a freaking lion that's still
seems to be
juvenile it doesn't have a mane yet but
it's a freaking 500 pound creature that
could easily kill them
starts running up to them and you're
like oh no what's about to happen and it
jumps up
and it hugs this dude and then it's just
like
licking him and hugging him and
frolicking and then it goes up to the
other guy and the same thing happens and
they're like laughing
and it's one of these things you're like
what it's what i've seen this before
like on tiger king you know i've seen
people interact with big cats that were
raised in captivity but this
these guys are in the middle of africa
the bush
and this thing comes out so the story
behind this is that
uh again late 60s there's two australian
dudes
who see a lion cub for sale in england
because there was a an exotic animals
market at that time
they purchased this thing not they're in
their early 20s
they're they're not trying to take
advantage of the thing they're just like
let's
who knows where this thing's going to
end up let's give it a good life and
they do this they raise this thing
in their apartment in their flat in
england
and this lion cub
grows over the course of a year and is
their pet and
stays in their house rides in the back
of their convertible mercedes
everywhere they go around town goes to
parties with them becomes friends with
their friends
and there's like an account of him
jumping up on a woman
that was one of the lion's friends and
he accidentally like claws her dress and
it falls to the floor like oh these
crazy surreal this seems like some sort
of like wes anderson movie
where there's this lion friend who is
going along with these guys now
eventually
they realize this cannot continue he's
too big
he's never shown any signs that he's
going to hurt anybody but he doesn't
really understand his own strength and
it's probably not
moral to keep this thing in england
probably not
so they take him to kenya
where they just what drop him off or
whatever
and at this point you're thinking this
thing has never lived in the wild
surely this thing's gonna die well if
you watch that video you'll see one of
the things that happens is after he's
after they're interacting with this male
lion
all of a sudden a female lion comes up
to them and starts interacting with them
not in the same way but is basically
just right there next to them walking
around
curious and like coming up next to them
and kind of rubbing up on them
they put christian the lion in the bush
it came back three months later thinking
they would never see him again
three months later three months later he
comes up to them
hugs them like that and then brings them
his
wife and they meet they stay there for
nine days and they meet his wife and his
kids he's got a hit
they have a litter whatever the correct
term of cubs
so he's going to happen in three months
though uh
i think it could yeah babies in three
months maybe if you're a lion
i don't know what the gestation period
is i don't know if i've got all the
facts right but i do know
when he came back he had
uh he introduced them to his wife and
kids he made it
he made it he made it and he made it uh
and then they never saw him again i
don't know the story kind of ends there
but these guys when the video went viral
in 2011
they ended up going on like the today
show
and of course they were much older at
this point and then they signed a movie
deal where zac efron was going to play
one of them
and it was i don't think that ever
happened because i looked and i couldn't
find it
yeah the whole captivity thing is a
complicated complicates this
this conversation but i mean the fact
that there's you know
having a connection with with an animal
it one of the things this highlights is
how extraordinary
it was with an octopus you know
going back to that you know because
they're just
you know you might have one in an
aquarium but you're not going to have an
actual relationship
this connection and it was just
it's mind-blowing does it make you think
twice i like them more about
enjoying octopus at a fancier restaurant
it gives me an easier excuse
to to uh not eat it i think you don't
like it i've had it a couple of times
and i and i really do hate it but
i've never i've never seen it on the
menu and said i gotta have this
and i'm the exact opposite so as i see
if i see it on the menu
i order it without exception if octopus
is on the menu i ordered what about now
ah man this is tough
seriously and you cried three times
well again i'm not trying to go
philosophical here and i'm also not
trying to justify my
own behavior but just go go with me on
another little journey for us
okay okay don't hold your dog up in the
middle of it just stay with me
i'm not um
i've thought about this and i thought
about this as it relates to
the morality of eating meat right it's
something i i actually think about it on
a pretty regular basis right
um and if you follow that sort of
oneness idea
and that we're all connected i mean
first of all the distinction that we
make between plants and animals
uh obviously it's there's there's a
there is a distinction between plants
and animals there are some weird sort of
intermediate things
uh and i do think that for whatever
reason
the closer something gets to our level
of intelligence for good reason
it becomes weirder to eat it right
but everybody draws the line at some
point some people say anything
with eyes anything with a face some
people say anything with a conscience
as however you define that
but there's a lot of there's actually a
lot of evidence to suggest that there is
a level of consciousness amongst
plants right when you eat a plant you
are
killing it um you're constantly
murdering microorganisms that have some
level of consciousness
just by being a person meaning that
there is a give and take
that happens between beings in the
universe now there are some things that
you can point to that really seem
totally unnecessarily exploitative
like factory farming as an example right
when you
begin to see an animal simply as a
as a source of food and its existence is
just for the benefit of you
being able to eat exactly the right kind
of beef that you want or whatever
and then of course what the net effect
of that is is that there is an animal
that is being bred in a certain way in a
certain environment that is
just to be eaten which is different than
hey there's a deer
that's out here enjoying its life doing
its thing
being a part of nature it's going to be
killed by something eventually
right it's usually animals in the wild
don't usually die of natural causes they
end up getting eaten by predators
and so there are points in which a human
enters the food chain and says i'm the
predator and i'm going to
anyway i believe that you can kill an
animal for the purpose of it being food
and do it in a respectful way that is
actually respecting its life i think
that that's a possible thing to do
so all that to say
from a moral standpoint while i
understand
someone saying from a moral standpoint i
will not
eat animals period i think that uh
it's it's a much more complex thing than
a lot of people
maybe are willing to to admit because
there's a lot of gray in
in that equation so you really do
octopus
uh well what i guess what i'm saying is
again
not trying to defend myself and justify
myself but i honestly feel my
perspective is
i can be absolutely amazed
at the octopus appreciate the octopus in
a way that i never did
before um and still
eat the octopus like i don't i don't
even know
what i'm saying is i if if i if i get to
a point where i have to
disrespect an animal in order to be able
to eat it
i'm not saying you know i'm saying i
don't disrespect i don't think that cal
a cow's life is
is is is pointless i don't think that i
have sympathy
for it for a cow i eat beef at the same
time
and i you know listen i may get to a
point where it's like
that contradiction is something that is
truly a contradiction that i can't live
with
uh but i actually think there's more
compelling reasons to stop eating meat
than the moral dilemma around the life
of an animal
but anyway well what what about this
what animal would we each
choose wild animal we choose to have a
best friendship with
that would remain wild not not
domestication not making a pet not
putting in a pen
or in your house or in your convertible
but like if you could go and
go into on their terms be friends with
that animal what would it be
i really like the idea of of of being
of like scuba diving i i can't do this
the
the uh the skin diving you could though
no one can do it at the beginning that's
what i've heard i know no one can do it
at the beginning i have an
anxiety of like holding my breath like
everyone has that anxiety that's why i
we were we talking about this before oh
it was that book the book i told you
about that i wanted to do a whole
episode on that we i don't we can talk
about it later
but the guy talks about in the book well
i know that everyone has this
anxiety but but like i would love to get
my
my scuba lice i've wanted to do that
ever since i've been snorkeling
a couple of times like man i want to go
deeper but i don't want to have to hold
my breath
oh yeah they're scuba diving i'm
actually more freaked out by the scuba
than
the free diving so i'm well
i'm actually so i'm thinking in that
realm
it could be an octopus for me now it
could be well i think you got to pick
something original
that's been done you have to have a my
you know my
sea bass teacher yeah i don't think
there's
i mean i mean there's some some of the
mammals in the ocean
anyway any mammal an adoption but that's
a dolphin connection
uh so i don't know i i guess i do want a
seahorse
you like little horses uh they're not
smart
well what if they are you don't know
that what if you could have a little
seahorse that just nestles up into your
chest region
yeah that's cool i would want one of the
bigger ones though the biggest seahorse
is for you
how big do they get i think they can get
as big as your thigh
no no way a seahorse gets that big maybe
as big as my foot
i don't think i see yours gets that big
i think maybe at some point a size 11
foot
you ain't this u.s size 11 shoe
well i got to ask this question now how
big can
a c horse get it
uh can range in size from 0.6 inches to
14 inches long that's a size that's a
size 14.
yeah that's a big that's a big seahorse
man you can find a big size 14.
uh can see horses kill humans is also um
and they
they could nuzzle well in a way that a
horse would it says might seem like the
most harmless unassuming creatures
undersea but they're actually one of the
most
deadly okay forget it just a normal of
course
you know i mean people have these
connections with horses there's like
therapy associated with horses like
they had they have this this like cosmic
connection to people
so i just got to go back to a regular
horse final answer what's your answer
but it has to be a wild horse
yep it can't just be like a horse in a
stable somewhere in burbank yeah
it it has to i only like a mustang i'm
going to ride it only by invitation like
it's going to have to kneel down
and kind of it like when when the horse
picked up aragorn when he was like
totally decimated he seemed dead and the
horse like
basically put him on his back
that that that's how it would have to
happen but it would after like a year
um well mine is my animal is
horse-like in a sense and it's also
i think i've been on record saying that
this is my favorite animal giraffe
um i'm a very i'm tall i'm very large
man
and the idea
could you imagine what it would be like
to be friends with a giraffe
just think about that for a second first
of all they're obviously so tall
gentle and sweet i've seen the eyelashes
on those things
and um
are also writable that's not i'm not in
this just for the ride
but riding a giraffe would be one of the
more badass things that you could do
again
this would be in the context of a
friendship it wouldn't be in a context
it would have to be initiated by the
giraffe i know there's no saddle i
wouldn't have a saddle made
uh i'd be riding this thing bareback and
i would be
holding on to its neck
i wouldn't even be grabbing on to its
its hair because i'm kind of like riding
a um
a hobby horse or like a carousel horse
yeah and this is only
if again if i was invited to ride it
but i think that if you are in a
friendship with a giraffe i think that's
part of it
i just think you'd be walking with it
and it would just be
i think i might grab onto one of his
legs
like one of those little stuffed animals
child that just like stays on a leg
and i just hold on to the leg and go
around and then occasionally it throws
me up
and lets me walk up its neck you're kind
of missing the relationship
it i was looking for more of like you
would read aloud to it
well this is all part of it you read
aloud just talking about
okay is that your final answer and there
is
a place there is a hotel yeah it's
called disney world
there's a hotel in africa oh where
again i don't know i don't know if these
things are like just on the premises i
don't know the situation i'm not
advocating like pet giraffes like
giraffes need to be in the wild
but there is a hotel where you eat
you're you're in your room and you're
like eating breakfast and the giraffes
come in and like interact with you
i think it's giraffes i've seen this
yeah i've seen a picture of it
i don't know about the i don't know
about if it's ethical so i'm not saying
i'm doing it if they're wild giraffes
that have somehow just become
comfortable with people
then i might go if they're like drafts
that they're keeping and making interact
with people for money then i'm not even
part of it
but i think that's where the hotel comes
in well i mean
maybe the drafts are what are the drafts
getting i don't know yeah
i'm just saying you're out in the wild
you're reading a book to a giraffe just
keep it pure
you're the one muddying everything
just keep it pure man listen the world
is complex and when it
and when it gets attacked you can't
intervene
i don't know what i would do in the case
of anything that can hurt a giraffe
i'm gonna tell you right now about
something i could do something about but
you as a seahawks
i would intervene with my friend because
i'm not a nature documentarian and
that's why i'm not
because i want to see horses to be i'm
going to do everything in my power to
protect
my seahorses well my seahorse friends
they're not mine i don't own them oh so
you dig about a seahorse
i'll talk about it as yours i thought
you went to landforms that's right
i could have a i could have i could have
both okay so
tell us what you think you know what
yeah i know
you don't have to tell me what you think
about the controversial things i said
there's
there's already enough of that just tell
us what you think about
just tell us about octopus teacher what
does the octopus teach you
yeah hashtag your biscuits we'll speak
at you next week
to watch more ear biscuits click on the
playlist on the right to watch the
previous episode of your biscuits click
on the playlist to the left and don't
forget to click on the circular icon to
subscribe
if you prefer to listen to this podcast
it's available on all your favorite
podcast platforms
thanks for being your mythical best